so good hey what is the status with uh
obviously miles Bridges was on your guys
is he still signed y'all don't nobody
leave this squad unless you just say I
ain't big Squad okay if you hear me was
he doing all right he's great he got a
contract uh we talked to him if not
daily weekly if I don't talk to him he
talked to him if he don't talk to him
brother talk to him like that's real
family yeah you know what I'm saying
like so he's doing shout out to him
being happy though that's all about to
say like we care about that [__] he's
happy he was going real trenched babies
man he was crazy
because like in a month in a minute for
a minute like he was in a slump like and
he wouldn't let nobody know but you
could tell him I can imagine he's
irritated by itself
you gotta understand like you right
there from I could only imagine how I
feel to be right there [__] days away
from the biggest payday of your career
or your life insane and some [__]
happened like had happened bro and you
just you know so like the prayers was up
for him at all times and we we glad he
apart of that bro that's important like
he back playing basketball you feel me
like he been doing music or keep doing
music and because he's a [__] good
rapper he's yeah he's dope but he a
great he's a basketball player for sure
and I feel like he just was getting in
his in his bag where people were like oh
he been in the gym every day and I think
feel like he gonna come back
and the [__] that he was about to get
they're gonna have to pay him like y'all
gonna have to stuff all that other [__]
in the trunk it is what it is man he got
through it [__] Rehabilitation all that
type of [__] yeah and it's gonna play
great like he already was playing great
and his everything all his averages go
up every year like it's a thing I do
with him before the season and I did it
down there every season and seven like
obviously couldn't do it last year but I
see my long-ass text message about how
much [__] I want him to do [__] and he
suddenly responding every time like I
got them [__] screenshots you feel me
and he do it the [__] averages go up
every season and I think from his career
has from that last season he about to he
about do it again about to go up again I
remember one day he told me like I think
we've seen him DeMar DeRozan did this
[__] too he told us he was playing a
business like I'm about to go for 30.
and this is about half time I did it for
30. and he only had about 10. wow what
did Mark tell you like he wouldn't
change his Kobe's
he's like 31 by the end of the third for
sure yo I felt for you and I really was
rooting for you
this last lottery
man that should hurt my feelings hey I
really ain't want to talk to the next
folks because I know the lottery before
about this I think you and I had spoke
right before the lottery before when you
guys got Ivy but uh damn dude I still it
feels like it feels like y'all should
have had women Yana no we spoke we for
sure we're supposed to have K and wimby
but in the same token [__] it like I'm
I'm I'm cool with with us getting twin
and I feel like us getting twins gonna
turn into some [__] that I didn't that I
didn't even know or expect to come about
him so with him Ivy during I like beef
stew huh who's twin uh I start Thompson
oh okay okay yeah we got it we gotta
start right oh yeah one of the two twins
yeah yeah sorry amen yeah we got we got
a Tsar we still got Jalen during like I
feel like he gonna get better and Jalen
Darren just grew like two inches yeah
he got to show me something him and
Marvin better like bro wise man gonna be
that way yeah
undoubtedly without him being can't hurt
he's a a basket rim protector I forgot
you guys also have the guys though here
run protector though oh you guys so you
think so this this one this I asked you
about ready about James Wiseman do you
think
it was simply touches
but that he left like no I'm talking
about no now why he left I'm saying like
is that why he didn't flourish out there
because he didn't get enough time to
hoop he was injured from himself I was
saying he was healthy when they traded
him though you gotta think how I'm gonna
play James Wiseman and I'm coming off a
championship season yeah it's insane why
would I change the lineup it's no room
there's no room for nobody to grow in
Golden State Jordan pool just was like a
flower rose growing from concrete like
and he grew and then they got yeah it's
like it's no room they don't even have
the the pay like that the salary did
he's stupid hey if say if James Wiseman
had a big season how is that going to
pay him you're right no that's I'll just
that's that's the only question I got
but I'm saying that's the only question
I have like pertaining to him coming
from that way because a [__]
that said she like his niece still trash
like [__] like that you feel me like
more so
Marvin Bagley got a whole lot to prove
to me then watch me because I get I get
wise men to leeway and say like [__]
all right you was hurt a lot you feel me
badly badly you have done had an
attitude in Sacramento like you you
literally wasn't playing because you had
attitude my dad's videos of you in the
actual NBA game [__] telling your coach
no I ain't getting in when he trying to
sub you in but it'd be a lot of I feel
like politics it's like a lot when it
comes to confidence and and
um motivation I don't think a lot of
people be motivated to hoop for us
hey man y'all got Monty now the most the
richest coach in the NBA
I feel like my own coach I feel like he
can motivate them he will build the
culture yeah he'll build a culture a lot
of times just like this we got we have
I'm gonna do we still got Army
yeah we got we had homie one day homie
to play good the next day we come we
don't got me well we're here look we're
just playing homie
well he's playing behind me right hey
that's my my man Josh he works with Jay
Crowder so he will know okay Tommy was
playing good right he played good one
game right right the next game we come
to I'm sitting on the floor he like yeah
I'm not playing this game I don't know
what reason but he's not on the lineup
for the game he told me he wanted it so
it's just like right that's not
motivation to keep playing good if I I'm
playing goodness
that's some [__] like I know I know he
told me I will if you hear me Casey had
to come to the moon and he don't play
with no more so [__] said he told me
out his mouth [__] didn't really
want to play for Casey because he's a
military coach like he type of [__] had
the [__] making their beds up in the
hotel oh yeah like an old school coach
for sure and he probably was like one of
the only [__] who was Pro Killian okay
he's here yeah
Hilliard been playing straight
what opportunity this season is the most
is the the best
how can I put it in nice words this
season this last season the only time
that I wasn't just full-on ranting about
killing Hayes on Twitter he was straight
he was he played decent he played like a
solid he went from literally but like
but all I'm like but brother when I was
ranting about him like every day on
Twitter guys I'm gonna I'm gonna run off
and pissed when I was ranting about that
[__] every day on Twitter he literally
was the most inefficient [__] in the
league like it was a stat on it yeah but
it's a difference of playing in
Australia where I think he's from
implant and
um and with everybody that could jump
run shoot slam dunk on you block your
shot from the top of the backboard it's
different like no it is now tell me this
I know you wouldn't have did it and you
probably don't remember that Dragon
cause I badly remember but [__] who you
you would you think you would have got
drafted what draft did he come in
or call Anthony right we could have had
Cole Anthony I told y'all
I wouldn't have even got certain I'm not
gonna even say the name because I I [__]
with buddy but I would have took
[__] Jalen um sucks I told you
all that and then in the Kelly age draft
I would have took Jalen Subs
no no no sex was in that draft it was
Jalen Suggs he can't we got a little no
Sexes after no we got Killian Hayes the
next year after we got
um what you might call it no Killian
Killian was here before okay
thank you thank you but I think Cole
Anthony came in that same draft no he
got drafted no Cole Anthony got drafted
with Killians no no the same here is
Killian because
the year before we got the number one
draft pick all right so I'm gonna tell
you so the draft that Killian was in the
number one pick was was Ant-Man
so we could have had
OB topping
Halliburton wouldn't have been good I
would have got Halliburton but cold
Anthony nobody knows I'm just saying
instead of Killian Hayes call Anthony
Tyrese Maxie Kelly
yeah
I would have got Tyrese for sure
and that's why he was the best one in
that draft bro bro
Maxie been nice since Texas in high
school like these be the [__] a [__]
like me and brother been paying
attention to for a while and know what
they about right I was a maxi fan bro
like staying at Kentucky bro what that's
what I'm trying to tell you like [__] I
DM that [__] when he still was in high
school bro like I've been like I've been
reaching out the only [__] you're
trying to tell like bro you cold you're
gonna be nice yeah bro my mama bro so
like when I see him in the draft and
then we pick Kelly and Hayes over all
these [__] that I've been watching
since high school that I know is gonna
come and do they Thug fizzle but this
it's a lot of stuff going to that [__]
pay all that [__] I don't know what our
cap at though I don't know how much we
got I think we got a lot of money coming
into next season yeah I don't feel like
we can't we ain't have enough to pay
these people bro
um talking about the pigs that we wanted
to pick like once they would have got
good what
I understand so you'd be looking at [__]
from SAS that I don't know
yeah a lot of guys want to play in
Detroit a lot of people say that like
that's not a lot of people say I don't
want to go there
and then who am I to pick somebody that
don't want to play yeah why would I pick
you if you don't want a beer I mean [__]
that I hate that [__] you're good enough
a lot of people say that like I
absolutely you don't know how many
people said I absolutely don't want to
go to that's what happened with Josh
Jackson he told the Celtics he wouldn't
play for them so then he fell to us and
you know shout out to Josh good guy but
Jesus that didn't end well for us yeah
he ended up on the two man no great guy
he's my baby yeah no we know Josh
Jackson used to be he actually pulled up
to the club in Phoenix I was DJing you
were performing and Josh came through
that's my little brother man
when I we used to walk in the gym
Josh was like
LeBron James to Detroit bro Josh is so
good like if you watch him in College
Kansas come on you had to see him in
high school like for sure they shut gems
down like